[Music]
companies invest a lot of time and money
to make sure that they will find the
perfect logo to represent their brand a
picture says a thousand words but
sometimes people don't get the same
message it can have a lot of negative
consequences and even be dangerous for
people's lives make sure you watch our
video until the end to know more about
the secret message you were supposed to
see in the new Pepsi logo if you want to
watch just one more video the premium is
the platform where you should go get
early access to videos from the things
the taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place with
ad free browsing click this link to sign
up for the premium and get ready to
binge watch videos from your favorite
channels if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe to the thing and please give
this video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you ten biggest logo fails of
all time London 2012 during the Olympics
the country invested a lot of money in
their logo more than four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars the shapes were
based on the year 2012 and it came in
vibrant colors the organising
committee's goal was to reach out to
young people around the world and to
inspire everyone to achieve personal
goals they thought that it was more than
a logo it was a brand that would take
them forward for the next 5 years but
many people didn't see it this way and
the organising committee wishes that no
one remembers their logo anymore
it was compared to a broken swastika the
symbol of Nazism as most people in the
world don't have the privilege to be
white heterosexual men it was an insult
for many of them Iran also threatened to
boycott the Olympic Games because it
looked like the word Zion a biblical
term referring to Jerusalem these
controversies affected the participation
of several countries so we can say that
they totally missed the mark but that's
not all the logo was also dangerous for
people's live how is that even possible
the animated footage used to promote the
new brand triggered seizures and people
suffering from epilepsy epilepsy action
said that it could affect up to 23,000
men and women in the UK who suffer from
photosensitive epilepsy and some of them
already went to the hospital they
immediately removed the video from the
website and created a better one we
never thought that a logo could fail so
bad ooh
this company caused a lot of
controversies when they offered to
replace taxis instead of paying for an
expensive taxi driver we had the chance
to pay a lower price and benefit from
what many people call a better service
with freelance drivers but many people
believe that they were stealing the job
of taxi drivers who have more
responsibilities than a random guy
driving a car should we protect the taxi
drivers or is it okay to look for
something better this is a question that
many people ask and as we were getting
used to over something else caught our
attention and left many people
scratching their heads
uber changed their logo instead of the
letter U that we all recognize they
change their logo too we don't even know
what that is
according to the company it represents
bits and atoms how could you find a
worse way to describe a company with a
simple picture there are bits and atoms
everywhere it has nothing to do with
uber and it certainly won't help them
stand out one of the reasons why some
products are so popular is the logo when
we often see a logo we get more familiar
with it and we start to be more
comfortable with the company this is why
it is easy for us to make a decision but
this time
uber was already popular and easily
recognizable changing their logo was
nothing but a bad idea that made them
waste a lot of money sci-fi channel if
you like extraterrestrials mad scientist
and time-traveling you probably already
know this I fight channel in fact more
than 80% of Americans who own a
television receive sci-fi the channel
owned by NBC features science fiction
horror fantasy supernatural paranormal
and more these kinds of shows are often
associated with nerds there's nothing to
be ashamed of the channel didn't want to
be associated with that this is why they
changed their name and their logo
because they believed it would make them
cooler and they believed it the right
way to appeal to young people was by
spelling their name in a different way
in 2009 the sci-fi channel was changed
to simply sci-fi with the letters wide
but instead of making it more popular
amongst teenagers it just made them
laugh at that time sci-fi was also slang
for syphilis an STD and this is
certainly not something that anyone
wants to have people also make fun of
the new spelling by calling it C fee
instead of sci-fi but changing the name
of their brand also came with a lot of
advantages they were able to protect it
by a trademark so it was easier for them
to market it and make sure that no one
would mistake it for another brand
moreover it was not only about science
fiction anymore so they were able to add
reality shows to their programming the
new name isn't so bad after all
we already got used to it Apple most of
us see this logo every day whether it is
on our cell phone our computer or
Apple has become one of the most popular
brands in the world and we can see
people waiting for hours outside the
store to buy the newest iPhone you
probably don't remember the very first
logo which portrayed Sir Isaac Newton
sitting under a tree this one wouldn't
look good on a computer but many people
could remember the second logo the
rainbow apple that was used from 1976 to
1998 Jobs wanted to come up with
something more modern
the colors represented that he wanted
everyone to think differently some of
you might notice that the colors of the
rainbow were not in the right order but
Steve Jobs made that choice because he
wanted the leaf to be green so what is
wrong with this logo the 80s were a hard
time for Apple and the logo was too
expensive for them the computers were
manufactured with metal casing instead
of plastic ones and the rainbow didn't
look good on it this is why the company
came up with the monochrome logo their
mistake was fixed and this decision was
probably one of the best they ever made
the Apple still exists nowadays and we
can see it almost everywhere just
because you fail doesn't mean you can't
make things change and find something
better Apple is one of the best examples
of that Hydrox most of you don't know
anything about this brand but once you
see what they're selling you will
immediately recognize them these two
chocolate cookies with icing in the
middle look like Oreos don't you think
and these two brands are actually really
similar but you'll be surprised to know
that Hydrox came first the brand started
selling cookies in 1908 Nabisco copied
them four years later when they
introduced Oreos those who knew the
first brand new that hydrops was better
because the cookies were sweeter and
made with healthier ingredients but if
you try to find Hydrox cookies nowadays
you won't be able to buy them because
they don't exist anymore why were Oreo
is more popular than Hydrox cookies
it all comes to branding the name
hydrops had nothing to do with cookies
it was the combination of the words
hydrogen and oxygen that would have been
cool for water bottles but it didn't
inspire customers to buy desserts the
company didn't talk to branding experts
and customers and it was their biggest
mistake even if you have the best
product in the world people won't buy it
if you can't find a good way to sell it
and this is exactly what happened to
Hydrox Oreo is now one of the
best-selling cookies of all time and
hydrox will be lost forever this is the
proof that looks do matter after all
starbuck if you are a coffee lover you
probably can't resist the temptation to
go to Starbucks every time you see one
and this is not good for your wallet if
there is one right next to your school
or the place where you work we have to
admit that we always feel a little less
lonely when we see this familiar siren
on the logo and this is why people were
pissed off when they saw that it changed
in 2011 on the first logo in 1971 you
could see the mermaid with her breasts 6
and her legs spread we understand that
the changes throughout the years made
her more family friendly we can all
agree that the siren is what makes
Starbucks recognizable and don't worry
they didn't get rid of her she was so
popular that they got rid of the
Starbucks coffee and let her alone on
the logo instead to commemorate the 40th
anniversary they thought that it was
enough for us to recognize the brand we
still do but that doesn't mean that we
wanted it to change fans started writing
on social media that the company needed
to leave the siren alone they didn't
want her to change the company received
more than a hundred responses on their
website and most people were not happy
if you want to celebrate 40 years of
success why would you do it with
something that risk to be a failure take
a note Starbucks JC Penney one of the
reasons you might not know this American
department store chain is that you
didn't need to buy windows or appliances
before 2012 it is the year when they
changed their logo and lost a lot of
customers it all started when the new
and now ex CEO Ron Johnson tried to make
the company cooler this man was known
for making Apple really successful in
retail stores and he wanted to do the
same with JCPenney he rebranded the
company to simply JCP and changed the
logo he thought that this new design was
hip chic and modern but he should have
known that what he thinks doesn't really
matter if that's not what the customers
think the logo awareness decreased by
28% meaning that people didn't recognize
the store anymore the store sales were
down 32% and the stock was down 46%
people said that it was the worst
performance in the history of major
retail losing more than five hundred and
fifty million dollars in total in one
year Ron Johnson was only the CEO for 17
months and it was enough for him to
totally miss the mark he didn't work
there anymore and was replaced by Mike
Coleman this new CEO made sure that
everything went back to how it was
before including the logo he probably
hopes that no one will remember what
happened to JC Penney in 2012
as it was a terrible year for the
company Tropicana for many of us this is
one of the first logos that we see every
day we all love to drink a big glass of
orange juice in the morning and
Tropicana is always there for us but
there was a time when we thought that
our favorite brand suddenly disappeared
what happened at that time once again it
was because someone randomly decided to
change the logo in 2013 we usually don't
look consciously at logos because we
recognize them in less than a second so
when Tropicana came up with the totally
different branding we didn't even take
the time to look twice and just thought
that the grocery store doesn't sell our
favorite brand anymore and it's not easy
to miss as Tropicana takes a lot of
space in the juice section many people
think that customers also had trust
issues
they liked to buy a product from a brand
they knew but when the packaging changed
it made people believe that the product
changed too with the generic look they
started to think that it was a generic
product and they didn't want to see that
in their fridge the consequence was that
their sales dropped 20% in one month
companies should learn a lesson they're
changing their brand is not only about
hiring a designer they also need to make
sure that this is what the customers
want and this is what could save them
gap
here's another brand who didn't learn
anything when they saw that many other
companies fails with their new logo we
all know gab as a clothing store but
when it's looked changed we didn't
recognize it anymore
once again this mistake was made because
companies didn't ask for customers
opinions before the new logo line on
October 4th 2010 the logo was supposed
to represent gaps tradition from a
classic American design to a cool modern
and sexy look but that's not what we see
in it with it the logo of a cheap
grocery store or an old book store we
don't know what this store is selling
anymore this time the company did not
only receive negative comments people
even created the website Kraft logo to
make fun of the situation people could
enter any text and see how it was
transformed into gapps logo the company
was really optimistic and decided to use
the negative energy in a positive way
they said that they were thrilled to see
such passionate debates unfolding if the
customers didn't like the new logo they
could share another design but the
crowdsourcing would never come the logo
lasted for only a week before they
changed it back to the original logo
which makes it one of the worst logo
fails we have ever seen at least they
didn't spend too much money on that and
this fail gave them a lot of attention
Pepsi in 2009 Pepsi paid 1 million
dollars for its new logo they said that
it had something to do with the golden
ratio numerical harmony and the Earth's
gravitational field they even mentioned
the Mona Lisa the Parthenon and
Descartes
but we're not sure about that and we
don't think that anyone understood the
secret message they might have
scientific facts to back it up but we
shouldn't need to have a Doctorate
degree to understand a simple logo the
designers won't be happy to hear that
many people see something else in that
logo it is a fat man holding a can of
Pepsi once you see it you will think
about it every time you see this logo
but this is not the only logo fail
associated with Pepsi don't you think
that their logo looks like the logo of
Korean air we hope that people won't
mistake these two no one wants to
accidentally end up in another country
when they
wanted to buy a drink no matter what the
rebranding was a total waste of money
Pepsi changed the logo many times over
the decades but coca-cola barely changed
theirs it seems like this last solution
is less expensive and really efficient
too no need to change a logo when it is
one of the most popular in the world and
everyone already likes it are there any
other logos that you don't like don't be
shy to tell us about it in the comment
section below and that's it for ten
biggest logo fails of all time if you
want to know more about logos make sure
you watch fifteen famous logos that look
very different back then thanks for
watching
[Music]